[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Ros M how are you guys I hope
you're having a wonderful Tuesday or
whatever day you're watching or
listening um I appreciate you for
listening to the podcast and supporting
it it's a little podcast that keeps
going thanks to you guys listening and
uh Patron my patrons if you if you don't
know what a patron is um they're folks
who support the podcast by giving back
and you can go to patreon p a o n.com
inside of you become a patron I'll send
you a message and uh there's a lot of
perks and it's a lot of fun uh it's like
a big Community now a lot of people have
become friends and family and it really
supports the podcast and keeps the
sucker going so if you like the what
you're listening to appreciate if you
did that um also you can go to my link
Tree on Instagram at the Michael
rosenbom on Instagram and go to the link
tree and you can see Cameo and I'm on
Cameo and the what conventions I'm doing
and anything else I'm doing music My
Band sunspin you go to sunspin
there's merch there you can get zooms
you can go to
talkvikes
scripts signed and ship keys and
tumblers and a lot of pictures autograph
pictures so you know they're coming from
me cool stuff um very exciting and I
also want to give a shout out to Spooky
Empire in Orlando I had an absolute
blast Peter thank you for having me um
it was just a great time being at a
horror convention Ryan with you know
like Robert England Freddy Krueger and
Heather laying camp and Nightmare Elm
other nightmare Elm Street people and
the Lost Boys my friend Jason Patrick
kefir southernland was there Nick Frost
who we love he was there um it was a
great time great time so thank you for
that great weekend I'm going to go there
next year whether they invite me or not
I'll just go and Shop I I bought so much
stuff uh it was so so much fun it's uh
they do it around Halloween every year
so you guys got to go to that um what
else what else the animal rescue mission
if you want to donate they're amazing my
friend Shira animalrescue mission.org
homeless situation food onfo foot.org um
Ronald McDonald House helping families
while their children are going through
major surgeries or dealing with a lot um
these are places that I give back to and
I appreciate
and uh yeah you know what's funny is we
have a big guest potentially coming on
it sounds like it and Ryan might not be
here I can't tell you the guest in case
they cancel but it's like the biggest
guess we ever have and Ryan is going to
try and work it out well yeah oh you
can't miss that one whoa
um I don't know uh great show for you
today I mean it is a it's a good one
it's John Glover I mean he was my dad on
Smallville
you can't beat that it's so much fun
talking to him I'll tell you it was
serious it was funny it was
um it just was uh I learned a lot a lot
more than I thought John's been on
before but this one you know made me
tear up a little and um very honest and
raw uh I think he felt like it was
therapy at times and I hope you guys
feel the same way um what are our
handles so people could follow us well
they're inside of you pod on Twitter and
inside of you podcast on Instagram and
Facebook and you can watch on YouTube if
you want but subscribe r a review on
Apple it really helps the show and
spread the word uh without further Ado
let's just get into it let's get inside
of my
Father John
Glover it's my point of view you're Ling
to inside of you with Michael Rosen
B
[Music]
inside of you with Michael rosenbom was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience all right we're here with uh Mr
Glover uhhuh uh you know what's what's
kind of funny is I'm going to speak for
Ryan but Ryan here doesn't have a
microphone today because we didn't set
it up but uh so don't talk to him and
ask him questions you could talk to him
but he just can't answer but Ryan uh has
been watching Smallville for the first
time on our tville podcast so he's a
little uh would you say you're a little
excited yeah I would it's cool to see
you in person yeah yeah after what we're
three and a half what two and a half
seasons in yep uhhuh two and a half yeah
uh three and a half two and a half
because we're oh yeah yeah we're almost
done anyway we're watching you know we
watch talk Phil and most of these
episodes I never saw I didn't watch him
you never saw them I didn't watch the
show you never you never once saw
yourself on Smallville I I did in the
beginning and then I stopped watching
why was that cuz I didn't want
to I just felt I would be diff I would
be better if I if I wasn't aware of that
I didn't want to look that way or this
way or whatever way you were
self-conscious you didn't want I didn't
want to be self-conscious about it when
I was working that I you know do you do
that a lot have you done that with a lot
of your work where in the beginning I
used to look at myself all the time and
love to and then uh and then as I get
older I I stopped why is that I don't
know cuz maybe because I'm older you
don't do you I was going to talk to you
about that because look you're not old
you're very youthful you move around
like you're still how old do you feel by
the way cuz you're 79 yeah how how old
do you
feel
11 you feel young Adam looks at me and
he says you're 11
[Laughter]
uh no I I I still feel like I was when I
felt I was in my
20s really yeah so you still have that
do you wake up does it take you longer
to wake up because for me with my back
it takes me a while to wake up I'm kind
of like out of it do you wake up early
or you have a thirst for life I yeah you
wait what time well this morning I got
up at 5: why well well cuz I thought it
was 6 but I was
up what do you do for all those extra
hours well I get the papers okay right
and the the woman across the street from
us uh Bev uh she's you know so I get her
paper and go put it over up on her uh
right she has a sort of a a thing right
up on her outside her front door and I
just put it so she doesn't have to bend
over is she older pick yeah so so I get
I get her older first I I her get her
paper yeah I get her paper and put it up
on her thing and then I came and and
come and get our New York Times she gets
the LA times we get the New York Times
and then and
Adam maybe gets up at 7 or 8 usually
right and so so I have that time to read
the paper and you do this every morning
you wake up you get her Bev's paper you
get your paper you have coffee you get
going right do you feel like you know I
always feel like if I wake the later I
wake up the less time I have to deal
with myself that I have not as much time
to fill the day so if I wake up at I
still wake up early I wake up at 8: uh
but you know there's a lot of hours in
the day to do things so you know do you
are things different now that you're you
feel like you're older like you don't
feel like there's enough to do you're
not doing enough that you feel bored or
you're always keeping yourself busy well
see when I'm not well I don't know what
the busy doing what I mean I knit
scarves all the time you do you've
always done that well not always well
yeah on Smallville you used to knit
scarves and things Yeah well yeah but so
I'm making things but but still I mean
if I'm not working I don't have a
job uh you know I'm much more
comfortable being the characters I play
that I am being me so it's cuz I
understand I'm not me
it's like so it's Freer I can do things
that I wouldn't do for me right so do
you feel like you're uh but learning how
to be comfortable with you more now you
you're forced to be more comfortable
with especially with the strike now are
you is that I you know I don't know I I
haven't worked in a while no one has
yeah but I keep thinking it's something
that's wrong with me well you can't work
because there's no there's no work to be
and I and I have a fear now cuz my mind
isn't ASP as sharp as it was cuz I I I
don't even remember having to sit down
and learn
lines I I mean I would read you know I
could I could read a speech and pretty
much get it so I mean it just they came
in my head that doesn't happen anymore
how so you have to go over your lines a
lot more well well
I'm
well but I
have I mean do you have to go over them
significantly more than you well I I
don't remember cuz I don't I mean this
is only recently how recent maybe a year
or so that I've just but I but I haven't
I don't I don't even remember what the
last time I worked was well you did The
Walking Dead Fear The Walking Dead oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and you had a
lot of lines in that yeah and you
managed to do it oh yeah I did that yeah
so I guess that was the last one and
that wasn't that long ago was it wasn't
a year or two yeah well that a year a
long time I mean that's a lot but it
sounds to me like you have the same kind
of thing as I have is is it's not always
comfortable being you know you're used
to playing a character doing things and
when you don't you're you're brought to
you're in a situation where okay now I'm
with myself a long periods of time yeah
and that kind of [__] with you and the
and the day is boring it's like okay how
many scarves can I knit mhm so there's a
point where I have to stop and then what
do I do every day I mean I do my hike in
the morning Adam and I go walk around
the top of the mountain to start the day
and then I think what the [__] am I
going to do today what I did yesterday
or yeah so it gets kind of mundane yeah
yeah I think but I think you're not
alone I think a lot of times you're
probably in your head you're
thinking what am I doing what am I what
am I I'm not working I can't you know
but I think everybody feels that way
what do I do with myself that's why you
know people usually have kids they have
to tend to their kids they have $10 you
don't have children you have your
partner Adam you have a life you can go
out to dinner when you want you can
travel when you want you can do all
these things but it sounds to me like
your whole life and it's obvious you've
been acting since how old
um teenager yeah yeah it started in high
school and then college and then I moved
to New York when I got out of college
and I started working almost right away
it was when all the regional theaters
were starting around the country you
know so I learned in front of
audiences cuz I was too chicken to take
a class cuz I I thought that that the
other actors were probably going to be
better than me and I wouldn't be well we
all go through that yeah yeah uh you
know you started doing all this theater
you started doing all these things I
think your whole life my point is your
whole life you've been acting and all I
have also realized that you know for a
long period of time even today I need
validation I need like I'm on a set
great job you see it people like you
people and when you're not doing
something when you can't get that away
from
work where do you get the validation mhm
and do you think that's part of it do
you think you miss that valid
I guess the camaraderie and all the
other things that you know take place on
a set but do you feel like you like to
be
validated yeah that's what I do I act I
be other
people you be other people I be other
people I create other people and you do
a great job of it obviously thank you do
you want to do this till the day you die
do you want to act as long as possible
yeah I'd like to say oh I I saw John
Glover on stage when he
died die on stage really yeah that's you
want to work to the last minute yeah why
why cuz that's what I do that's what
gets me off
well there are other things yeah but
that's the best thing when I'm doing
somebody being somebody else it's
freeing really that's that's how you
your excitement is being someone else is
is yeah you how you thrive yeah
pretending to be someone else is it is
do do you love yourself I know that's a
really weird question but I mean do you
like yourself can you look in the mirror
and go you know John I think you're a
good guy I love you sometimes I like
myself sometimes I don't what don't you
like about yourself
U uh less I see I grew up less than cuz
I was different than the other little
boys I you know my dad my dad was so
athletic and he taught T me how to hit a
ball and throw a ball and do a football
and throw football and he taught me well
but I wasn't interested in it so so I
you know what I was made fun of a lot
when I was in school cuz I you know cuz
you felt you were different people
thought you were different yeah less
than and that and that gave me this
feeling of being less than so but I
found I remember in high school I I we
were doing the of Being Earnest I think
that was the play with Jun Allen
kitsmiller right yeah Jun Allen
kitsmiller Jun Allen kitsmiller she was
a good actor too but um and she could
sing I sing off key so I can't do
musicals but I love musicals I did too
yeah uh yeah but it it uh you did that
but I remember we had a uh like a in the
cafeteria there was a uh where where we
did the play the whole school came you
had to play in a cafeteria yeah well we
didn't have a stage so in the cafeteria
room they put yeah they took the tables
out and set a platform up and they did
it there and there was a an assembly
where we sort of did a preview of it and
so I was sort of you know with English
accent and everything and I was doing
the thing and people started laughing at
me and it felt I I I I had control
of of of all these people that that I
went to school with a lot of which did
who didn't like me or anything but I
could make them
laugh today's sponsor neutr sense.com
uses a CGM right here under my arm which
is a small device that provides
real-time feedback on how your body
responds to the foods that you're eating
your exercise stress and even your sleep
now this is something that look guys if
you see I'm wearing it I am wearing my
glucose
monitor because I have found out I'm
going to get into this so just give me a
second uh Nutri sense really monitors my
glucose levels so when I find myself
crashing
tired you can just take your phone
because there's an app I put it under my
arm the sensor retrieves all the
information and it shows my glucose
levels for the last x amount of hours
and I go wow I [__] here well that's cuz
you had three root beers dude maybe you
shouldn't be having so much root beer
maybe you should keep your glucose
levels at a even place so you feel
healthier you feel better you feel have
more energy um you know it's not just
for people who are you know I guess
diabetic or whatever it's for people who
want to live a healthier life and that's
what's happened to me I didn't know what
this was and neutri sense changed my
mind on this whole uh outlook on on on
health um Nutri sense helps you analyze
your glucose levels in real time in
response to food exercise stress and
sleep Nutri sense includes one month of
free board certified nutritionist
guidance and
support uh it really is awesome Ryan if
you want me to get you one um you could
your your life it's it it shows you what
you're eating and and and what you're
doing you can monitor all that you take
notes on this and it's just so easy to
say okay I remember I crashed I was
really tired at 2:00 why well right here
it says well you spiked and you crashed
and this is why this happens and if
you're if you like if you work and
you're doing all these things you need
more energy you monitor your
glucose and it's just amazing my
nutritionist helped me interpret the
data and promptly answered all my
questions Patrick thank you Patrick over
at nutrients I said well what are these
see how it spikes here and spikes here
well well what exactly are you eating
and drinking Michael and they you know
we managed it and I said well what's
what are better things I could have in
my diet that I can get some energy but
won't crash and so he sent me a list of
things so it really is wonderful in in
just the short time that I've done this
I've noticed better sleep I've noticed
uh sustained energy less brain fog it's
because I'm not doing eating all those
bad things I'm not having all that sugar
and it's really helped me and you know
I'm 51 and I no matter how old you are
you want to have sustained energy
throughout the day and right now visit
neutr sense.com
inside to save $30 and get one month of
free nutritionist support that's
nutrients.com
inside do you know I had I've talked
about it but I the same thing when I was
a little boy I was the smallest kid I
was not popular all this stuff you guys
listeners have heard this but I finally
did a play and it was the first time
anybody paid any attention to me it
where the same we're the same any
attention a popular kid walked down and
said the hallway the next day and said
you're really funny in that play Y and I
from that moment on from a 16-year-old
boy 17-year- old boy I said not being me
is what I'm going to be we're the same
and I think that's why a lot of my
depression a lot of my anxiety
throughout the years and I'm you know uh
I I I think it's because all of a sudden
you get to a certain age and you have to
spend more time with yourself and I
spent most of my time on sets and making
people laugh and entertaining and being
the clown and but when the clown y yeah
when the clown comes home you know what
happens so dealing with yourself and I
had like a midlife crisis and I just I
didn't know what to do with myself and
you know all I can say is at least it's
happening now but you know do you think
you know who you are at this point at 79
years old do you feel like I know who I
am I know who John Glover is or are you
still kind of figuring who you are out
now that you're spending more time by
yourself well what I'm trying to figure
out is how to make the the days not so
boring but I used to work all the time
people would say that oh you're always
working you're always working and I was
always working cuz I would take jobs
sometimes i' take jobs that they my
agents would say don't do that don't do
that don't do that but but I I just
wanted
to it was my play so what can we get
John to do to fill these
days you know get him an acting job
there are movie theaters there are
there's a lot of things to do in LA
there are parks there are events there
are why don't you put yourself out there
you say you're going to do something
three times a week three three nights a
week and during the days a few days make
a sort of a write down a list of things
my therapist told me to do this like
fill your schedule with things they
don't you don't have to pack it but like
have something what's Monday it's going
to be another boring day what what what
can you do to change that what can you
do for Monday what can you where can you
go what can you experience I mean at 79
you've probably experienced quite a bit
[Laughter]
yes I'm not going to get into Freddy
Mercury
again I can't believe you don't remember
having sex with Freddy Mercury although
you know you did I mean if I had sex
with Nicole Kidman I would go I remember
sex with Nicole
Kidman yeah anyway we don't have to get
into that I know that
recently I heard that you quit drinking
wine You' you've been you've been
hanging out with Paul Williams MH and
you've been doing these cons and Batman
stuff and the great Paul Williams um
who wrote so many great songss do you
know he
wrote uh the
Carpenters what he wrote that song We've
Only Just Begun no Monday um what's that
one Monday Monday Monday no I think
that's moms in the P I thought so anyway
but you you supposedly you you quit did
you quit drinking or you quit drinking
wine and why did you do that because I
found if I drank one glass
uh it it threw me
off in a bad way yeah so I stopped and I
thought okay I thought first I could
just drink one and then I just drank one
and it was it it tilted me and you
didn't like how you were acting did
people ever say hey I don't like you
know how you they that's when I had too
much cuz I used to you know go to dinner
and have a just keep
you know a bottle of wine a bottle of
wine and then another bottle botle if
there yeah but but it it got so I could
only if I had one it would it would
throw me off kilter and I thought can I
can I really do that stop and I and I
don't miss it now are you that's good
that you don't miss it but I but I
remember there was a some I remember
there was somebody else of guy in
Baltimore that used to be very very
funny he was older than me but but but
he started uh when he would drink it
changed who he
was and I and I thought that's that's
happening to me now yeah and I I didn't
like it here's what people don't
understand you alone are enough you're
just enough you're you have such a great
personality and there's so much fun to
be around you don't need it especially
you say it Alters you it makes you
someone else that's sort of I don't need
a lot of people said oh remember when we
got shitfaced at I go I wasn't drunk I'm
just fun and I probably look like I'm
drunk I don't need it I've never really
loved alcohol but it's good that you're
aware of it and that you're like you
know why do I need this MH you know um I
know that we've talked about this in the
past I know that you're a big
Alzheimer's Advocate and you do the
walks you did it for your dad who passed
away from Alzheimer's my grandfather
died of Alzheimer's my grandmother died
of Alzheimer's now being like 79 years
old are you sort of Obsessed or thinking
oh my God what if I have Alzheimer's
because every time I forget something
I'm like oh why don't I know this why
don't why why can't I think about this
you just said this does it kind of like
uh weigh on you like I got to go to the
doctor I got to get a CAT scan or
whatever the hell they do I I yeah it's
I I I I wonder if if it is a
yeah I wonder about that so I I mean my
memory is not as good as it used to be
like I say so I don't know if it's going
to get worse or or or if
if and then uh you know the if I got to
play you know you usually have at least
four weeks of rehearsal so maybe I could
get that you know those four weeks
in know I want to play a I want to play
Prospero before I
go that's a demanding role yeah big big
I did a stage reading of it once with
some people so we we read it but
we but I didn't so we didn't have to
learn it and I think could I learn it
now I mean is is my mind that that okay
do you would you if somebody offered it
to you would you say yes even out of
fear yeah you would do it even if you
were like I don't know if I could do
this I you would just take the
chance you know if if if is that scary
to you yeah
yeah um but I I uh what I what I'd hope
to do if I if
I you know could find a place and to do
it and a good director who would worked
with you yeah um
um you jack O'Brien
who who I'd want right because I've
worked with him a lot and Shakespeare
and stuff down at San Diego uh and yeah
yeah so uh but if if I had enough time
to just you know if I just read it read
it every day every day every day every
day I think I could I think you could
too and I think it probably gets in your
head cuz I Haven an acted in a while I
haven't done this this is how we all
feel when I don't act for a while I'm
like I don't I don't think I can learn
these lines I it would take me forever
and you know what it would and then once
it kind of you got it and your me your
your mind it's amazing how you train it
you train it by learning and learning
and learning and memorizing and when you
don't it slows down and goes back to
like kind of the way it might have been
or worse but it's it's like anything
else it's a muscle so I you know the
fact that you have The Bravery to be
like [__] yeah I do it is amazing that
you you take it cuz I would be chicken
[__] be like no I'm going to start out
with just a couple scenes and if I like
that and if I'm doing it I'm managing
I'll work my way up I'll build it you're
like going Prospero I'm like Jesus
Christ John but you've always had that
that attitude since I've known you
you've always been one to take risks to
try things to be creative a good scene
partner I mean I you know working with
you I I think I improved substantially
as an actor because I would learn my
lines even more because I wanted to in a
way impress you I wanted to I wanted you
to almost like a father figure like I
wanted you to be proud I wanted you to I
wanted to show John Tony Award winner
all these things I wanted to I wanted
you to like me and respect me and and
and uh I I always put a lot of weight on
that sort of thing just because just to
make me better and it and it did
um but I guess you don't lose that you
still have that that in you you know I
hope so well you do you do do you want
to just do you I think that
maybe you know what would be good for
you maybe good for me what if we just
got into an acting class or what if we
got into something [__] just to
sharpen our skills and start working on
scenes I did that when I was here
because when I moved out got to
California and I started making
money then I would take jobs and make
money but I but I wasn't enjoying uh the
work yeah and uh and I there was a
teacher that I know a lot of people
worked with out here a man named Milton
celis um and I thought I should go to
him and I so I asked somebody at the gym
one day that I knew that studied with
him can I go to a class and look at a
class and he asked Milton and Milton
said yeah bring him bring him bring him
and so I studied with him and and he
said Milton said to me one day he said
you'd closed up shop you'd
stopped it's like you you weren't
working anymore so he got me back to to
enjoying the work again so see that's
what that's
interesting because I think it's the
enjoyment I miss but I don't look at it
anything as enjoyment in terms of you
know acting nothing really inspires me
so I wonder if I could bring back that
element of like you remember in college
or high school when you're just reading
scenes with people or you're just
improvising or you're playing games or
tongue twisters and there was an element
of fun and my therapist told me you have
to do whatever you do there has to be an
element of fun in it or you're not going
to enjoy it
so maybe that's also what I need maybe
it's some getting a teacher like that
goes let let me bring the fun back he
died oh that's not fun that's not fun
no this show is sponsored by better help
Ryan you ever feel like your brain is
getting in the way of living your best
life all the time yeah I would say so
like you know what you should do what's
good for you but you you just can't seem
to do it oh yeah yeah therapy helps you
figure out what's holding you back so
your brain can work for you instead of
against you and this is what happens
with um therapy you're you have all
these things bottled up and you need to
let them out and you need to talk to a
professional it really really helps
therapy is a great way to learn positive
coping skills and how to set boundaries
it empowers you to be the best version
of yourself and it's way more convenient
with better help it's entirely online
and designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your SK schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire it took me
like a minute it's so easy even I can do
it then you get matched with a licensed
therapist switch therapist anytime for
no additional charge seriously it's not
uncommon you meet someone you're like I
want to try someone else it's easy just
like that betterhelp is truly the best
way to make your brain your friend give
it a try visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10% off your first
month that's better help h
lp.com
inside inside of you is brought to you
by qualia senolytic I've been using this
stuff for months on end now and I can't
imagine myself not taking this if you
want to feel better if you want to have
more
Focus this stuff really works have you
have you heard about analytics Ryan I
have yeah it's a class of ingredients
discovered less than 10 years ago and
they're being called one of the biggest
discoveries of our time for helping to
promote healthy aging and helping to
enhance your physical prime your life
goals in your career and Beyond require
productivity but let's be honest the
aging process is not our friend when it
comes to endless energy and productivity
and that's why I use qualia senolytic if
someone would have told me that there
are science-backed ingredients that
could help help me feel 15 years younger
in a matter of months I I wouldn't
believe it no one would believe it but
then I tried qualia
cytic uh it is honestly changed me in so
many ways talk about hyperfocus now uh
what's great is I only take it two days
a month so you're not popping pills all
the time this is so easy two days a
month and you're going to notice a
difference and you're going to be like
whoa uh it really made me feel that way
uh the formula is non-GMO vegan gluten
free and the ingredients are meant to
complement one another factoring in the
combined effect of all ingredients
together
100 day money back guarantee no
questions asked that's the kind of
product I like um when they give you a
100 day guarantee because they are
obviously confident quas analytic gives
me higher energy levels I feel 15 years
younger for crying out loud uh I'm more
productive no doubt about it I'm more
enthusiastic about uh life I have less
aches and
pains think thank you qualia analytic
what makes the qualia brand unique is it
has fully transparent formulas that are
created by top scientists MDS and NDS
science-backed formulas back with
hundreds of research citations powerful
results thousands of real life-changing
reviews over six years in counting read
the website 100 day money back
guarantees zero Financial Risk to try
any quala formula help resist aging at
the cellular level try qualia cytic go
to neurohacker
docomo 15% off these statements have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration the products and
statements are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease that's
neurohacker dcom inside for an extra 15%
off your purchase thanks to neurohacker
for sponsoring today's video inside of
you is brought to you by discover if you
like using de debit over credit don't
you think it's time you also get
rewarded well now you can with discover
cashback debit it's a checking account
that rewards everyone with cash back on
everyday purchases plus there are no
fees period we're talking date nights
thrifting the latest trends nights out
with your friends and it's now earning
you cash back with discover cashback
debit check out eligibility in terms at
discover.com
slashback deit Discover Bank member
FDIC what um what fun things did he
bring back to you he just I don't know I
mean I started I did more scenes than
anybody in the class cuz I mean I just I
I started acting again I started working
again and I and I was loving the work so
but
but yeah
this not working and and this you know
our this strike that we're
on who knows it put you in a little bit
of a l yeah so I I don't know where to
go but you know but it's but
that stage actors we're we're not we can
work that's true we I mean yeah stage
actors can work I believe right yeah I
mean it's not part of the amtp is it I
don't know uh have you
struck have you stried no no no you
haven't no I don't want I want to work
but no no I mean have you do you want to
get out there and strike with your
fellow sag members with other actors
yeah I understand it but I haven't gone
out would you I yeah I guess I should
well why don't we go one day okay me and
you and just go strike for an hour and
then have lunch all right we could just
strike and uh support support the cause
okay I think we should all right do you
obviously this a stupid question theater
or film if you had to
choose
theater why is that well that's where I
started and and and and when you're
doing it um you you kind of know if it's
right because you can feel the audience
whether they're listening whether
they're laughing or not laughing or
whether they're weeping or not
weeping but but that's that's sort of
where I
learned in front of an audience and
that's sort of also the instant
gratification the immediate validation
right exactly do you go to
therapy U yeah you do yeah you have a
therapist yes and what do you talk to
him
about I don't know sometimes I don't
feel like I don't know what else to say
like the other day we were talking he
said you got 10 more
minutes I said I don't know what to say
so he said okay and we stopped so I
think well may I don't know M maybe I'm
not being honest with myself and there
are things I need to talk about that
we're not talking about so I don't but
but now with us
talking I we do Tuesdays so so maybe
next Tuesday I'll talk about some of
this stuff I think that's I mean that's
that's it's it's you being so honest and
open like I said I mean before it people
listening they can people can understand
they could it's just it's real it's real
and it's you know it happens to all of
us and we all have our demons and it's
like you know for so long I I wanted
everybody to like me including my
therapist I don't want you to think
there's anything wrong with me then why
are you going to therapy you know but
ultimately you know you have to we have
to dig deep I just had therapy right
before you came and I started talking
about disappointment and how much of a
disappointment I think I've felt as a
child that I was always disappointing
everybody my parents and people and I
just wasn't this I wasn't that and no
matter how much you work on things it
carries it stays with you even a part of
it will always stay with you that's what
I call less than when I said less than
that's that's what I feel about myself a
lot less than and exactly me too but but
you shouldn't you shouldn't feel less
then because look at everything you've
achieved you have and that's hard
sometimes you're like I know I know I've
had success I've had I've made money
I've worked with great people but I
don't feel that and that's what therapy
is for is to try and break through where
you feel it you understand it you
connect with it and you don't let it
rule your life and you try to make
changes that will um fulfill that void
you know what I mean so I think that you
deserve it I mean as you know you're
you're a wonderful human being there's
not a more giving lovable talented guy
out there um and you deserve to be happy
even though you know you may not feel
like you know you're trying to
understand all these things and look I'm
I'm saying this because I feel the same
thing I I I I struggle with it
constantly and um but it's worth it it's
worth it to just say you know do you
tell him I feel less
than you do tell him that and he says
why I don't know what he
says well get a new therapist I mean
that's what you need do you uh do you
think about do you you know I I used to
obsess about death do you obsess with it
with death do you think about oh my God
how many years do I have left or how
many or does it not concern
you yeah I just wonder how it's going to
happen I I hope it goes quick well of
course yeah I don't want to Suffer Well
here's the thing you I'm I
I mean my next birthday I'll be 80 which
seems sort
of I've never been 80
before that's big that's a big number
it's you know my grandfather lived till
he was 95 he got Alzheimer's though at
90 but like his body and everything was
like if he didn't have
Alzheimer's he would have lived till 100
and he had a good
life so I think what we do too is I you
know like oh my God I'm 40 I can't
believe I'm 40 I'm so old then I'm 50
and I'm like why was I [__] thinking
that when I was 40 stop thinking about
how old you live live now yeah there's
no reason you can't start doing things
that make you happier there's the
strike's going to be over you will work
again you'll be doing those things but
in the meantime now's a chance to work
on you now's a chance to find out what
makes you tick what makes you sad what M
what what drives you what hold you back
it's like work on all that that should
be your mission now that's that's your
work do that and try to fill your
schedule with things to do you know go
to New York more often how often do you
go to New York I'm going next Friday
Saturday Sunday whatever day what are
you gonna do you're GNA go see some
shows after Salt Lake City I'm going to
New York and you're going to go see some
shows I'm sure
sure and you love that yes but when
you're sitting there watching it you're
like I want to do this yeah
yeah yeah yeah are you uh do you feel
like you're more critical as an actor
watching other actors or are you
um are you able to sit back and really
just enjoy
things I remember there's this thing
that when I was uh doing Lisbon travata
I was studying about kalas and she said
uh you can learn from anybody good or
bad good and bad so you know I've tried
to look at that and if there you know
some actors that are doing something
that not honest or truthful or whatever
I I try to look at it and think
what right yeah yeah right so what he's
doing is so you just learn from everyone
yeah but you still enjoy shows you go to
shows and you really enjoy them sure
yeah is it like a whole night out that
you and Adam have a nice dinner you go
see a show well sometimes yeah it
depends I mean there some stuff I see on
my
own um very rarely usually we we look at
those things
together
uh but
U yeah what about what about shows here
what about Los Angeles what about
there's so many shows they're doing here
at the Pantagis and things why don't you
go to more shows here
you know I don't rightly know and I I
I'm glad I came here today so uh yeah we
should go see some stuff here I would go
see a show with you yeah I think that
would be a blast yeah that doesn't that
sound like fun you're like what am I
going to do this week well I'm going to
go see a show I'm going to go have lunch
with an old friend I'm going to go to
this park that I haven't been to there's
so many places that I haven't even been
to and I need to do these things too
so um
you know you I think sometimes we have
to open up our eyes and just and and
there's more to it than just what's in
front of us mhm you know a lot of times
I'm in my house and I'm like H okay just
interviewed John I guess I'll take a nap
I like naps do you
nap sometimes what time do you go to
bed uh
around 10 or so and you wake up at 6
yeah that's a long day
that's a long day yeah it
is that's it's hard to fill your days no
matter what I mean look at Ryan over
here don't ask him a question because he
can't talk but like you know you know he
he probably has days where he's just
bored off his ass and he's a lot younger
than we
are bastard son of a [__] do you do you
uh look you're known a lot is well in
the film world not so much in the
theater world as being a like playing
great villains
do you love playing villains was there a
time in your life you're like I I don't
want to play the villain anymore I don't
want to play that bad guy I don't want
to I want to play you know this or did
you how how how did you work with that I
don't
know what I kale what's the critic's
name from The New Yorker all I remember
is Canby kale yeah she called me in the
in the New Yorker she called me the
prime rter of the80s
the prime rer meaning rotten characters
yeah yeah villains yeah Prime rer of
the80s that's awesome I know it was
awesome well how could you yeah yeah but
the villains move the play along yes
they do they're the most interesting
active yeah sure they're the most
interesting yeah uh especially when
there're subtext and there's uh
development in the character and reasons
why the character is bad all that stuff
you know used to play lion Luther you
always told me and it just resonated
throughout the the run of the show for
me was
that you have good intentions you I'm
not you're like I'm not evil I I love my
son yeah cuz people you know the
villains they don't I mean
nobody yeah they don't think they're old
but see but but they started writing
what they they were going to make me a a
a villain when I the you when we started
and I thought no no no and this was when
I was studying with the with Milton when
when when all that happened and he and
he would used to say you're not going to
get this all together just start
sneaking this stuff in so so that's what
I started doing yeah cuz I realized no
this man is a father and he's trying to
make his son a better stronger man and
and so and slowly the writers started
picking up on that yes and and going
with it so I felt I felt I had a lot of
power with them I don't know if there's
a character that we talk about more than
you on the show about how much your
performance like we talk about Annette's
performance a
lot but you we always talk about on our
other podcast how much you bring there's
a there's there's an episode well we'll
bring that up later but there's there's
just these moments where some
how you feel for Lionel even though you
hate him he does these things to you or
to people to other characters and then
you're oh but but the way you play it
it's so ambiguous it's so
uh subtextual or whatever it's so uh
just it's it's layered it's not just bad
bad bad cuz it's easy to play that and
how many roles do you see where a lot of
times you're like oh guy he's just bad I
saw this movie they remade Fright Night
2 I know I'm a big horror movie nut nut
uh I have the poster Tom Holland signed
it but they made Fright Night two and I
like the movie but the thing I thought
didn't work was the lead character that
was originally played by Chris Sarandon
who we both
love uh Chris sandon played the nextdoor
neighbor who was the villain with such
charm mhm and you liked him and but he
was so bad he was he was the bad vampire
and in this one they just he was just
bad and it just wasn't didn't have near
the impact and so that shows you that a
lot of times it's in the writing if they
would have written a scene or something
showing that he wasn't he was layered
and you charismatic something right and
a lot of writers failed to do that and
the fact that they said they started
catering towards that um that sort of
gift that you brought the
show um you know I've never done a
character it SE seven years cuz they
they killed me in in um I killed you D
yeah I know and that was I killed you
and I and I talked to the writers I said
listen when you do write me
off let licks kill
me cuz I figured that that would really
be who you became that was the thing
that pushed me over the no pun intended
push you out of window yeah yeah you
told them that I asked them I said
listen when you kill me let Lex do it
and that that and they bought it that
was one one of the most Pinnacle moments
of the show to me for my character
anyway for us both of us and the look
you gave me it was almost like I
remember doing the scene with you I
remember and I don't remember a lot but
we're standing there I'm about to push
you and you just looked at me
like letting
go and when you're falling out the
window sorry for spoiler alerts for Ryan
did you know that
happens yeah anyway he uh you fall and
just the look in your eye it's almost
like you're at peace with it like it's
time it was time and this is the way I
wanted to go it was just I don't know it
was enigmatic and and and heavy and but
you always brought that and it always
like CU I would get bored I would do
scenes with certain people or you know
and it was like H I'm going to the bar
I'm getting another drink I'm just
sitting at my desk I'm getting knocked
out I'm you know this that the love
triangle but when I saw that I had a
scene with you I knew it was going to be
10 times better than it was on the page
because we were going to bring it
we were good together we were good
together we were really good together
yeah we were
um there was yeah there was an
excitement did you enjoy if you look
back do you think you really loved
working on Smallville was it something
that you go you know this was
a many years of my life that I I spent
on this show and playing this character
it's probably one of the most well-known
characters you played right yeah I loved
it I loved it you loved it and then you
know then then seven I was gone and then
nine and 10 yeah they made him just a
villain the the writers were they didn't
I was so I was so excited that when they
said an alternate universe that they
were going to come up with some great
stuff but they just played out
andout
stereotypical villains so you didn't
like that no did you tell
them what you going say yeah they it was
Beyond them they had yeah there was no
imagination in that yeah alternate
universe yeah well at least she had
seven good years remember you weren't I
had seven Great years I really were I
had a ball it's the longest I've ever
played one part what was the second
Brimstone oh they pulled the plug so
fast on that show really yeah well what
was the second long what other shows
were you on for long this was was the
longest cuz mostly you were film in in
theater I was what mostly you did film
in theater so you didn't do a lot of
like TV uh Series where you were regular
you played Parts like you were in Law
and Order right different done many many
parts but I've never spent seven years
with the same character same character
so it was and it was wonderful cuz they
were writing good stuff until 9 and 10
came yeah that's why I left in seven
when Allan miles left and you know
Kristen was leaving uh John Schneider
was already dead I'd already killed you
I'm like there's nothing left for me
there's nothing left for Lex to do here
you know he doesn't have this antagonist
anymore he doesn't have the antagonist
of John Schneider's character who always
had a b thing for Lex it was just sort
of I need to move on I need to move on
and you moved and it was funny because
cuz I remember they um the president of
the studio took me to dinner and
said what will make you stay for another
three years I said
nothing and he was so insulted goes look
at Julianne
margal I go what what about her well
what has she done since ER whatever it
was and I go and now fast forward she
did The Good Wife and got Awards and is
making so much money but he was just you
know doing using whatever tactic he he
could to get me to stay and then I said
well you know just make me an
offer and they offered me the same
money not a die more is that how you get
somebody to come back for three years
you just say hey you're mowing my lawn
right I know you want to mow someone
else's lawn but you know if you mow my
lawn for three more years I'm going to
give you the same money I don't know if
it's the best analogy but you get what
I'm saying but uh yeah I said no I said
no on that
um this is awesome I feel like this is
just having a conversation right that's
what we're doing yeah I mean I I really
didn't think of what I was going to talk
to you about I just felt like I'm just
going to talk to John when he's here
uhuh we've got into therapy we've gotten
into your days we've gotten into your
you know getting older
um does does Adam do you guys you've
been together so long since what 80 30
years 30 years yeah do you call each
other out on whatever you don't even
hesitate you're like John you're being
an [__] John this Adam you're being a
dick do you guys say that uhhuh and you
talk it out yep we're learning sometimes
but we we're yeah well we get we're
better I mean it's taken a
while to to Really iron them
out we get through them what's the key
to a a good relationship or one that
lasts 30 years what do you think Honesty
I guess do you think you weren't always
honest in the beginning and throughout
you just it sort of
developed yeah
yeah
yeah who is the best actor you ever
worked
with oh the one that just sticks in your
mind you're like this this is this is
the best actor I've ever worked with
besides me oh boy you know I I wanted
uh
it's almost that I did and I chickened
out too Geraldine Page had a company she
worked for a little company right she
made no money but she did all these
plays that she wanted to do and there
were they were was some Replacements cuz
I I worked with her in white
nights yeah um and um so I guess I it
would be Gerald and Paige cuz last night
we watched a sweet bird of Youth have
you ever seen her do that okay you got
to watch her do sweet birdy youth
sometime she does the film of it um and
she's just genius but um but uh she
offered me they she wanted me to when
this one guy was leaving to replace him
and I thought I I don't know if I could
do it without a rehearsal period so I
made up a lie that I I had another job
and couldn't do it when was this it was
uh it was years ago years ago yeah you
regret
that uh yeah cuz I could have worked
with her you know in a in a I mean the
when we did the movie it was I mean I
didn't I I played we were in the same
scenes together but it wouldn't have
been like really playing with her right
so so I regret that I was chicken that I
didn't know but but I it was because I I
didn't didn't know if I could pick it up
out of
midair and without a rehearsal
period um yeah fear fear got in the way
yeah yeah well fear gets in the way
sometimes I think fear is okay sometimes
fear is telling
yourself usually it's because you know
you don't think you could do it and you
should try to overcome that fear but
sometimes fear kind of tells you this is
going to be a lot of work a lot of
stress it's going to [__] kill you
it's going to be like exhausting
mentally and physically do you want to
do that do you want to feel like
that no I don't so I'm not going to do
[Music]
it
but but I like to work so much that I
probably would have done it but it was
the it was just the fact of of of going
in being thrown into it without a a real
rehearsal period right but who's the
best the best actor you've worked with
you think Geraldine pagee is the best
actor based on the movie you did with
her or is there someone else whether you
did a play when you won your
Tony uh someone you were like this was
one of the best actors I've ever worked
with I've Welly I I I've worked with so
many good actors I but I don't know
nothing rings as as the the most special
one right so I just a lot of good actors
yeah have you worked with any actors
that it was miserable to work with them
yes where it just was not fun yes was
Bill Murray one of
them no oh okay I just want he was scre
he was in Scrooge right yeah oh no he
was great to work with he was oh yeah he
I mean there was one one line that that
after we was walking anyway I couldn't
figure the the line in the they wrote
didn't make much sense or anything but
right after lunch he just said I got it
this is it say this right so right right
when he was I was walking him to the
elevator and uh and I knew what the line
was and everything and just just just as
the elevator door was uh closing I threw
the line at him and you could see him go
like that so he was terrific I loved
working with Bill Murray really oh yeah
why does he have a reputation no well
you you hear some stuff but he's one one
of the legendary you know actors but
like you know some things came out and
some some some people have told me he's
not the most pleasant person to work
with oh I found he was great yeah great
I like that who was an actor that I mean
you don't have to throw maybe hopefully
they've died I'm not going to name
anybody that I didn't like is there
someone who intimidated
you
uh I
no I can't think of anybody cuz I
usually sort of know what I wanted to do
yeah W with it you know yeah and I'm
alive
to I saw Geraldine paage in one of these
plays that at that little theater where
she made no money just doing these
things and there was a moment she had it
was an ibson play it was about the son I
think there's somebody get syphilis or
something and there was this moment that
she did with her son where you thought I
mean she was trying to love him but she
sort of went like like
something I I I Can't Describe what it
but it was something it was something
that was just soar whatever and when uh
we were flying back from when we were
doing white nights we were flying back
on the airplane together and she was
talking about you know rip her husband
and da da da and this play and that play
and I said there was this moment with
your son in the play and she said oh
that boy he used to drive me crazy I
hated acting with him and what I saw was
was was
herself
being but but it worked in the play
being upset with him yeah but but but it
worked she used it yeah she she I mean
she hated working with him and probably
he said something that was like blah
blah blah something and so she was like
oh yeah she just took it took it away
she was in the moment I mean did you
when you were
younger when you started doing plays did
you want to be
famous I it was not fame I wanted to be
act an actor but you didn't care if
you're were famous you just wanted to be
an actor well the famous part would be
nice but I mean I mean I
yeah but that was not my the the it
wasn't your goal my my goal was to play
play parts to be in plays and but I
think I think that's partly true I think
that we you know like we talked about
earlier the validation you get and like
that feeling you get when people
immediately respond to you and like you
and validate you and the
audience I think that it comes with that
it's almost like I I love this and I
want to be great and with that I want to
be famous and do all these big parts and
people to know me did you want people to
recognize you and know you and and and
give you adoration that that's not bad
no that's pretty good but it was it have
to do with some where where uh you know
you get this adoration you get this and
and with that be you become you get the
fame you get the fame and you get you
get both if you're a good actor if
you're good enough you'll be
famous and was there a point where you
thought I should be more famous I'm like
you were had such an ego did you ever
have such an ego where you're like I'm
so good I'm a Tony Award winner twice I
should be getting these bigger roles why
am I not being considered for these
blockbuster movies I only won one Tony
oh I was nominated for two but I only
won one okay so but but were but did you
did you ever get thinking cocky where I
think we've all thought that at once at
one time I I thought I should get a
press agent to you know to sort
of yeah so I guess did promote you and
give you more than you more uh right but
but I thought if if I did I could get
maybe better jobs right so so I don't
know what it was did you but but I do uh
I
mean I've written uh oh here's what it
was there there's there's this show that
was once upon a one more time it was all
the Once Upon a Time no once upon a one
more time it was a musical with all of
Britney uh what was Spears
Spears's whoops did she do Oops I did it
again okay so but it had nothing to do
with that it was a but that was a song
in it but the male song sang it I had to
get out of it because I uh I Adam was
sick and I and he said I need you to
take care of me and it was going to open
in Washington DC so I got out of the U I
had to quit the show I decided to it was
very decision but it but it was my
partner my life partner mhm and he
wanted didn't want to be separated
because he needed me to take care of him
yeah and uh uh and and I remember I I've
uh I I wrote a couple of uh uh like
letters or or whatever or somehow or
found a emails and and and and uh
complemented their performances
and and I heard back from them oh my God
coming from you I think you're a
wonderful actor I mean that's that to me
makes me very happy if other actors it
goes back to when I wouldn't take an
acting class because I thought the other
actors would would laugh at me or or not
laugh at me if I was being or would
judge me so so to hear it from a fellow
actor
go I'm so this coming from you makes me
so happy yeah I mean it just
that that your colleagues your your
peers when they yeah I I feel the same
way all right this is called [__]
talking with John Glover it's rapid fire
these from the top tier patrons I love
you go to
patreon.com inside you but I have to
think fast rapid fire you just have to
answer fast no no no you don't have to
be you can answer it as slow as you want
okay all right Nathan do you wish your
Walking Dead character had become the
Negan is that the character Negan of the
spin-off do you hope to one day have a
role like Negan and be a visceral bad
guy Negan that was that the character I
played no he
was uh no was Bobby no anyway oh no no I
know what he's saying he's saying like
the Negan of the spin-off like Negan was
a big role and so do you want to be like
the Negan of the spin-off did you want
see I didn't watch the show so I didn't
know what that is but you wish The
Walking Dead character had become uh a
lot bigger well yeah I think I I was sad
that they killed me off so soon I I
thought there was a lot going that I
that they could have I yeah I wanted to
stay on the show longer David P John
you're an amazing man I have no
questions but just want to thank you for
your amazing talent and sharing it with
us well who said that Dave
P who's Dave P he's my
Patron tell Dave you love him and thank
you Dave I love love you and thank you
perfect Jen T your partner is an
incredible artist are there any artistic
Hobbies outside of acting that you like
to partake in during your free time well
scarf making scarf making yes Leanne if
you could go back and give your younger
self a piece of advice what would it be
and why well if Geraldine Paige wanted
you to play with her I would play with
her
now she found yeah that's amazing
Michelle K out of all the amazing roles
you've had the opportunity to play what
one has stuck with you the most and why
this could be your own thoughts of like
which which role that you're like this
was the role for me this is the role
that I loved love playing this is the
one that sticks with me you know I did
this movie several marches ago I or it
was in March I remember it's called the
home it was uh uh James D James
demonico right did you watch those Purge
movies do you we these Purge movies I
know them well they scare the crap out
of me but he wrote this movie called The
home and it t about an old age home and
I was a resident of the
home but I also taught an act and I was
an off- Bradway actor and I taught uh a
class an acting class to the other
residents in the home and um and I
thought I thought this part was I I when
I read the script he offered it to me
and I read the script and I thought how
does he know me so well I mean this guy
W yeah it's not it's not been they don't
they're looking for a distributor of it
it's called The home you've seen it no
I've not seen it yet but I I I want to
see it now well I want to see it now too
they said they'd get when I got to New
York they'd screen it for me so I could
see it oh good yeah we you got to let me
know how that goes I will I will you
seem excited about it I I was so excited
about it I even did a a a one scene
where um where I was naked but butt
naked really yeah they don't show
anything I remember hear them saying um
cuz they were talking about the way the
scene was set up and the way the camera
moved and I heard the one woman was two
women cameramen the camera operators and
said well we okay no the chair is hiding
his penis so we don't see his penis
there are you happy with your penis well
it could be a little larger okay all
right Raj tell me about a recent time
you felt worry
free when I was doing this part I just
told you about yeah that's when you just
kind of well CU I felt it was me I I
thought how does he know me so well yeah
it was and I had a great time W waking
making making that Rachel D okay John I
was fortunate to see you on Broadway and
Nikolai and the others do you have any
plans for future stage work is there a
dream role you'd love to play on stage
well you said that already Prospero
Prospero yeah there you go okay um
anybody out there want to make a do a
tempest man that's a tough play yeah oh
it's so beautiful though so
look you have a lot to talk about with
your therapist now thanks to you well I
have a lot to talk about with mine it's
it's just part of the you know it's at
least there's not so much a stigma not
as much of a stigma attached to therapy
and you know being less than or feeling
less than it's like for so many years
it's just like you know I felt like uh I
don't I shouldn't my dad doesn't go to
therapy he doesn't do this he's he must
be a real man and I'm like no dude you
want to become a better human being talk
to someone get rid of your [__] you want
to feel better uh about yourself and you
deserve we all deserve to to you know to
love each other and all that but I love
you I do Mutual seriously I I I love you
and I would be there for you in a second
if you needed me and I feel the same way
about you you're my baby yeah thank you
thank you Dad this is always a pleasure
and uh thanks for getting so personal
and deep and honest with me
thanks thank you Michael
Michael
well I love you Johnny Glover you're a
tremendous tremendous Talent tremendous
man and
um I really really appreciate you so
thanks for coming on again and
supporting your boy I love you why don't
we uh get into the top tiers let us do
it top tiers these are the top tiers
that get their name shouted out in every
episode they support the podcast by
going to patreon.com tovil or
patreon.com inside of you uh become a
member today become a patron today and
uh we love you without you guys I
couldn't do this and a big shout out to
my producer Bryce who I love and and
Jason and Ryan who's here couldn't do
the show that you guys love you Ryan are
you good I'm good yeah I got up early
this morning and I'm tired and we we're
recording this in the late afternoon and
we generally don't yeah and that's why
we're tired yeah yeah it's hard to get
through it but it's uh it's fun when we
know we have good 11 a.m. 10 a.m. start
yeah oh I'm so tired but today yeah and
also it's November we're recording this
on November 1st mhm I don't know well
look it's November has just started and
it feels like the end of the year
already and I'm sad you know yeah I know
I'm kind of happy that for the next two
months I don't have a ton of stuff to do
yeah um not for the most part I hope
everybody's healthy and happy and uh I
also want to give one of my best friends
who I love and adore and is a big
supporter of this podcast Alex fatovich
I want to give her all my love and I
want you to give all your prayers
because her her papa passed away and um
she loved him dearly and he was an
awesome awesome man I got to meet him a
few times and he was what an energy a
ball of energy and Alex I'm almost
tearing up but I'm not going to do it uh
I love you and I'm thinking about you
and uh we'll help you get through this
we will there's a lot of love um here
are the top tier shout outs
Nancy D Leah and Christen L Lisa Yuko
Nancy D it was good to see you uh in
Orlando damn good Yuko Jill e Brian H I
miss you Brian we got to go to a concert
Nico P I Miss You Robert B I miss you
I'm GNA just say it to everybody Robert
B Jason W Sophie M Raj C Joshua D
Jennifer N Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B
Ashley Ryan Mike E Lan
Supremo 99 more Santio go M I got the
statue Chad W lean p matd s Belinda n
Dave H Sheila G Brad d Ray harada tabi
the T Tom n Talia M Betsy D ranne and C
Corey K Dev Nexon Michelle a Jeremy C
Brandy D Joey M Eugene and Leah so good
seeing you in DC and all the rest of you
Corey Angela F Mel s Christine s Eric H
Shane R Andrew M Amanda R Jen B Kevin e
Stephanie K jel jam and J lean J Luna R
Mike F Stone H stay wild moonchild Brian
L Kendall L Cara C Jessica B Kyle F
Marisol P Kaye J Brian a Ashley F Maran
Louise L Romeo B Frank B Jen T Nikki L
did we say little Lisa I don't see her
name on here April R Randy s Derek n JD
W oral P Ginger Insomniac Rachel d
laurelai l Melissa H Nicholas W
Stephanie and Evan Charlene a Don G did
we not say little Lisa little Lisa's in
the three spot as per us was she yeah
did I say that not clean up today but
she's uh bat in third oh Lisa Lisa
thanks for the shirt too Lisa thank you
everybody who sends me things some
people send me things and it's like a
stop stop sending me things you're too
nice and you don't need to I have enough
stuff you're so
nice gosh all right thank you so much
for listening I love you um from the
Hollywood Hills in Hollywood California
I am Michael rosenbom I am Ryan Tails L
wave to the camera and be good to
yourself please just do it love yourself
it's the holiday's coming up it's
important and we'll see you next
[Music]
week